hey everybody is Charlie I got a bunch
of requests to do a video for the Russos
teaser that they released yesterday they
were having a little bit of fun so I'll
explain what's going on
because they have talked about what the
close guesses are to the actual Avengers
for title if you're new to the channel
there's a new round of that infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video I name a new
winner at the end of this so what
happened yesterday is is that for just
like a brief couple minutes the Russos
posted a photo to their Instagram
account we know that it was theirs
because it has the blue checkmark so it
was their official account the title of
their caption was Avengers 4 titled
teaser but then it had a hashtag that
said infinite karma USA so people were
like wait what a little over 200 people
hearted the picture before they deleted
it so it was up for less than a couple
minutes because they have a pretty big
account at this point so anything that
they post people jump on pretty quickly
so the fact that they deleted it so
quickly pretty much lets you know what
was going on here 1 I think they took it
down because they were just having a
little bit of fun the Russos are known
to troll from time to time they just
like having fun with people and - I
think the reason they took it down is
because it was a little too close to the
actual Avengers for title and they
didn't want to get in trouble with
Disney while they were just having fun
like oh wait a minute we don't want to
accidentally spoil this when we're just
trying to do something funny the actual
picture said infinity mirrored room
aftermath of the Opel iteration of
eternity so people are like wait a
minute
eternity is a huge concept that they
teased during guardians of the galaxy -
we know it's a big cosmic entity within
the Marvel Universe so it makes sense
that eventually the cosmic movies will
start referencing some of that stuff so
it is on my short list of possible
Avengers 4 titles I will say what my
actual list is now it's changed a little
bit since infinity war came out but
what's going on here is is that infinite
karma is the name of an actual business
infinity mirrored room aftermath of the
obliteration of eternity is the actual
name of a real art installation in the
name of the art piece itself this is
what it looks like it's an art piece
done by Yayoi Kusama so you can just see
that it's a bunch of lights that look
like stars in an infinity mirror room so
that it looks like the stars go on for
forever the funny thing about that is it
Rousseau's confirmed that Avengers
Forever is the closest people have come
to guessing the title of Avengers 4
which is the name of a real comic book
story involving a lot of time travel and
there's just a lot of time-travel hinted
at during the ant-man the wasp
post-credit scene between the quantum
realm and the time vortices and all the
behind the scenes pictures we've been
seeing for the past year so it's
reasonable to assume the time-travel is
a plot device during the actual movie
but the Avengers forever story is
basically just a bunch of different
Avengers teams from different time
periods all working together to fight
against an older more evil version of
Kang the Conqueror who's working with
another Lackey to try and steal the
Destiny force which is this new super
cosmic force that's found after the
kree-skrull war in the possession of
Rick Jones we're not really expecting
came to conquer in the MCU so like a lot
of this you can tell is definitely not
what they're doing for Avengers 4 the
story doesn't really get into any
multiverse stuff and we know that's
gonna be a part of Avengers 4 it's
really just purely a time travel story
like they crack time so badly in their
destiny war as they call it that a
younger version of King the conquerors
like okay enough he turns on his older
self and helps the Avengers fix
everything so just don't expect Kang the
Conqueror as a character in the MCU till
phase 4 phase 5 I hoping that they save
him for the Young Avengers movie that
Kevin Feige teased a while ago I kind of
knew something was up when people were
sending me this picture just because
Kevin Feige had said that he wasn't
going to reveal the title for Avengers 4
till after they had posted the Captain
Marvel trailer and that's probably not
gonna happen till October so this is way
ahead of schedule so anytime something
like that happens especially when it's
done from an official account of people
who are like the Masters of not giving
away spoilers
you just have to suspect that something
fishy is going on the actual shortlist
of titles right now that i have are
avengers eternity like i said it is on
my list Avengers Assemble
Avengers forever even though we know
that's not the title they're like that's
the closest but it's not the title and
then right now my number one pick is
actually Avengers legacy because I think
that they're going to try and invoke
some of the same energy from the Marvel
legacies stories in the way it will
highlight the legacy of each of these a
list Avengers within the MCU
both the actors in real life
the characters within the story like
what is Robert Downey jr. 'he's legacy
in Marvel Studios he's the backbone of
everything that they've done be careful
if you tell that to him too much in real
life because his ego will get even
bigger he'll ask for an even bigger
paycheck when they ask him back for any
cameos during phase four and phase five
Peter Parker is probably the best
example of Tony Stark's legacy as a
character within the MCU like helping
Peter to become a fully actualized hero
in an a-list Avenger in his own right
him going on to serve a role like Iron
Man is serving right now like Iron Man
is the go-to guy the guy that brings
them all together the man with the plan
so in the future I think the hope is is
that they'll uh sure in these new heroes
and they'll take their places because
some will cycle out some will retire
some might end up dying but if you
didn't see it the Russos did a big video
where they actually talk about the
legacy of Robert Downey jr. and what he
means to all of these stories that
they've been telling Tony Stark is Iron
Man took it a lot of ways he is the
heart and soul of the Marvel Universe
Tony Stark's powers are fascinating
because they basically come from his
mind they come from his scientific
knowledge his brilliance his
intelligence and his sort of aspirations
it allows you to sort of track a journey
in the character and watch him evolve
and it's sort of better himself through
the use of these powers and he's a
fascinating character it's character we
love because he's imminently flawed and
we like characters that are challenging
and that expressed their humanity and I
think Tony Stark does that as well as
any of the characters he started off as
a narcissistic alcoholic and grew into a
hero which I think makes him eminently
relatable and why he signifies with the
Marvel
this notion of a character first and
that heroes are fine through the choices
that they make he's one of the most
exciting power sets of that name again
spider-man it was a great thrill for us
to be able to reintroduce this character
with Tom Holland playing spider-man and
and the relationship the special
relationship that he has been Tony Stark
kid
Devendra that mentor-mentee relationship
is very rich and complex and having cast
the character as a real teen we really
set up a very similar dynamic between
Robert Downey jr. and Tom Holland that's
very reflective of the characters Robert
was very much a mentor to Tom through
the shooting process and it's not easy
to play a superhero and I think Robert
was very instrumental in helping Tom
find that voice in him and for that
character it was very charming how it
was so reflective of the character
relationship so even if the title is not
avengers legacy i think that that's
actually like the next closest idea that
they're going for in simple titles
usually went out over really complicated
ones like Avengers age of Ultron or a
Captain America Civil War are probably
some of the longest titles that will
ever see for future Marvel movies
typically they go for titles with
shorter numbers of characters so like
Avengers infinity war would be
considered a long title I think that
Avengers 4 will be even simpler than
that as a concept but it'll somehow
encompass everything that they've been
trying to book in the last 10 years and
that is these actors in the characters
legacies the a-list Avengers that we've
seen since phase 1 let me know in the
comments though what is your number one
pick for the Avengers for title right
now after everything that we've seen so
far congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner from my last big video
Tristan wrote ish please email me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here to learn all
about Hawkeye during Avengers 4 and
click here for that spider-man far from
home teaser thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight